We're here at Chester Washington
Golf Course
in Hawthorne
slash Inglewood Adjacent.
It's time for Golf Beef.
[musical buildup]
- The beef is real.
- That's hood golf right there.
That's hood golf.
You come out here
and play in some
moccasins and [BLEEP].
- On the fairways of Golf Beef,
hitting it straight
takes a back seat
to talkin' that shit.
- Uh-oh.
That's Crip shit!
[bass drum note]
- That's Big Persy.
- [laughing]
[bass drum note]
- And that man
with the terrible laugh,
that's Red Grant.
These two light
bright brothers
are the originators
of Golf Beef.
- Now, did you get
the socks first or the vest?
[laughter]
- My crew played good.
I played good.
He played good.
- And I played well.
[laughter]
[mellow hip-hop]
- Where else can you go hang
out with your homeboys,
have a cigar,
get a couple drinks,
do something halfway athletic.
- Get mad at each other
and then say,
"Yo, you playing tomorrow?"
That's just how we do it.
- I don't get mad at him.
I be mad at
this shit right here.
[laughter]
- Not everything here
is exactly PGA-sanctioned.
- Golf Beef babes on deck.
Checking balls all day.
- James gotta go piss.
- Okay!
Sorry, y'all.
I had to pee out
all them bad shots.
- We smoking, uh,
weed inside of a cigar.
I'm playing with three bros--
- Look out!
Oh, shit! We almost got
the [BLEEP] knocked outta us!
- Was that Snoop Dogg's ball?
I think that was
Snoop Dogg's ball.
[hip-hop playing]
- My bad.
I said forehead.
- Yep. It's his
home course too.
- Teach Snoop how to say
[BLEEP] fore!
God damn it, you're supposed
to say "fore," [BLEEP]!
- I said forehead--"Watch your
forehead, here come the ball."
- Let's check out Snoop's swing.
He got a stiff-ass takeaway,
chains smackin'
all over his face.
He got them Greg Oden knees
look like two bent blunts,
and he got a slice
over the top swing.
Pfft! You make Charles Barkley
look like Arnold Palmer, man.
Look at Chuck.
Charles over here
lookin' like he workin'
on a railroad.
That swing is like the
Phil Jackson-Carmelo era.
It's ugly as hell,
and we wish we never saw it.
- [laughing]
- Chippa, dippa, dappa do!
One for me, two for you!
- Hey, man.
Uh-oh, mud!
I got Jordans on.
Have you guys ever encountered
any haters, any racists?
- Golf is a game
of equality.
- Right. Right.
- Yes.
- You feel me?
And because it's equal,
you know, everybody treats
each other equal out here.
- Remember, they didn't
let us in the golf course.
We was carrying bags.
Now we playing.
[cheers and applause]
- Take this shot,
you might fall in love.
- You know what,
I'm very professional,
and normally
on the golf course, I--
[laughter]
- But you--Okay.
Okay.
Is that--
is that Tanqueray?
- ♪ Tanqueray! ♪
♪ Tanqueray! ♪
- Okay!
[laughter]
That way!
♪ ♪
- Just like the winner
of the British Open
receives the Claret Jug,
Golf Beef
has its own rewards.
- This award goes to
the ugliest golfer out here.
- Yep.
- Okay.
- And not only will his
clothes be ugly,
but he's ugly.
And his game is ugly.
Mr. Danny Green.
- Danny Green!
Danny Green, everybody.
Danny Green.
For those who didn't
make the leader board, well,
they always have the next
Golf Beef to look forward to.
So it's all good.
- Next year,
my game going to be impeccable.
[laughter]
This was my first year--
I don't mean
to cut these brothers off.
- No, no, we love it.
We love it.
- Let me tell y'all this.
This shit's Golf Beef.
- Golf Beef, bitch!
- Yeah. Like they said it.